[Music]
cast away your childish needs there are
your mother bury your father tell me who
you are I am the ironist Danny ran comes
back to New York after being gone for 15
years as my building should sell it and
buy some shoes he believes it he'll be
received with open arms I'm Danny Rand
been away a long time the first thing
you realized this is that the world's
changed Ward joy his childhood friends
joy and ward an hour billionaires on his
father's corporation sorry but I'm
calling security boy no it's me they
don't believe it's him to begin with
Danny Graham is dead Warren don't do
this Danny just wants to do the right
thing but he has this fire in him
where'd you train can't we'll get there
from here
we find out he spent 15 years in a
monastery training to become this
warrior how you got that tattoo it's not
exactly a tattoo it's the market the
artist this horse that runs through the
universe the fire of the fist and Danny
can ignite it
Danny has been told his whole life that
there's a mythological dark force in the
world and he didn't really believe that
they were real or they are very real
they've infested Rand all these people
have their own agendas
even though who's good and who's bad
there will always be forces gathering
against you
disguised as a friend slipping past you
as a stranger they are everywhere
you knows who the good plays gonna be
it's really fun to go on that journey
with the character embrace your destiny
the show just hits you full throttle
this city is no place for the Iron Fist
I have a vision of total victory and
nothing else
[Music]
I'm Danny ran in a way a long time Danny
Rand hey I left here 10 years old and a
jet with my parents I became the lone
survivor Danny Rand back from the dead
why did you wait in this long to show up
how the hell did he learn martial arts
where'd you train come on
my father instilled in me a love and
respect for this company that has never
faded this is my home
Rand is my company this city is no place
for daddy
nope wouldn't anyone happen to you why
are you really back here some bad people
have gotten on the other side criminals
I know what they are but they came to to
fight them we need someone with special
skills I've been training my whole life
for this this is my person
it's time
I'm going with you no you're not you
need me
the changes coming down become what you
were meant to be
I am the iron fist how does that mean
bring it in
[Applause]
look you guys know